hurry Clinton bitter as ever she refuses
to give up the spotlight and can't get
over her loss to trump the failed
candidate is now being brutally mocked
for claiming 20/20 Democrats also
gabbard's a Russian asset but of course
the New York Times is defending her town
in Clinton as quote master troll welcome
to Hillary unplugged for most of her
public career mrs. Clinton has been
constrained by the expectations of her
position be it first lady senator or
Secretary of State now after her
stunning loss in 2016 it seems she
finally feels liberated to speak her
mind Greg have you noticed a liberated
crooked yes you know I believe she is
trolling patrolling is now officially an
old person's word if the New York Times
he's using it it's like your granddad
putting on his baseball cap on backwards
on his way to a Black Crowes reunion you
know it's a it's like when you're it's
like when you're playing Coldplay and
your mom says oh I like that song and
you just throw the album that the web
word is dead now to me I will never call
anybody a troll or talk about effective
trolling Thank You New York Times okay
what do you think about this puff piece
they seem to be enamored with Hillary
well that actually hello me Clinton
things the New York Times really did her
wrong yes in 2015 and 2016 remember
they're the ones who broke the Clinton
Global Initiative story she thinks that
they gave the emails think too much
attention etc but you have six how about
all of us think okay this week you had
the last two presidential runners-up in
the news for the wrong reasons so you
even have Bernie Sanders today saying
whoa like don't say that about tulsi
gabbard
like we don't need to have any of that
here tulsi gabbard not gets all this
additional attention and you have Mitt
Romney so these do you mean what's his
name yeah yeah two people who spent
their entire careers as viable
presidential candidates but they were
criticized because they were too canned
and too scripted well now you're seeing
the other side of that do you like this
new Hillary wand
you know she's tweeting she's saying
sassy things unplugged you know to get
back to Greg's news right yeah I mean
this is her she's you know I just to
pick up on what Dana was saying and when
I look at people who lost the
presidential races so I'm looking at me
Romney john mccain john mccain was back
in the senate going after barack obama
as I recall Mitt Romney's ran for Senate
and won in Utah you know he's even got
something to say about Trump right
nobody sells these guys to shut up so
why would you say oh he'll eree the lady
should shut up you know Tulsi Gabbard
Tulsi Gabbard is not only you know in
terms of the possibility of Russia
wanting her and encouraging her with all
the stuff online she said that no matter
even if she doesn't win the nomination
she plans to go to the convention and
create turmoil and I just think what is
the are you rooting against the
Democrats even as you run for the
nomination kind of like Ted Cruz cause
turmoil with Trump my favorite part of
that New York Times piece was for most
of her public career mrs. Clinton has
been constrained by expectations of her
position by be it first lady senator a
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton has
only been constrained by trying to be
somebody she's not to be likable to be
understanding to be empathetic rather
than just pathetic
her latest look is a has-been gasping
for relevance this is the equivalent of
a 72 year old almost 72 year old woman
taking butt selfies and putting them on
Instagram belfies I think this piece
runs now right that that only now is
Hillary Clinton a master troll really is
Monica Lewinsky did you want to bring up
something he's referencing emails there
was someone I think it was on CNN yeah
his name is Jeffrey Jeffrey let's listen
to Jeffrey this is also a story about
the news media about how much time we
spent on that and that's something that
I have felt a great deal of personal
responsibility for I think I paid too
much attention to them and I regret that
and this story turns out to be a big
nothing
and we spent months on it Hillary
Clinton very likely
the election because of it and I think I
should have been think talking about
other issues not about the emails so let
me get this straight
Jeffrey Toobin and his entire life
that's what he regrets you'd think to be
other things you were thinking about
covering Russia collusion yeah but
here's the fact the State Department
right has been investing it they said
zero and you guys don't even say he's a
zero what 1 0 that she did nothing wrong
there was no session didn't do anything
wrong Obama didn't do anything wrong
Hillary did nothing wrong no one does
anything brother wait a second a minute
ago you're saying okay Trump is
complaining because oh this impeachment
is terrible is not so the process went
goes forward Hillary is found to have no
response no account nothing done wrong
and you still won't say call me let her
off the hook that's how the cookie
crumbles